hmm today on our show the able bag.look
Dave's here come to all of us now Dave's
back we're not gonna bury the lede
Dave's back forever no party this mulch
in last time we talked about Dark Knight
this time we're having a small
conversation about ant-man and the
Marvel Universe stick around right now
fat man in Batman Begins
welcome back to another episode of fat
man I'm Kevin Smith mark Barnard and
with us again in this episode is Dave
this is mulch in that's right the small
chin is getting in here two small
[ __ ] face man he's gonna tell you
some more anecdotes for the small chin
adults if you will man [ __ ]
storyteller man we got a lot of react to
that last episode people like that dude
is [ __ ] good you think that's good
wait till he [ __ ] tells you wait I
dare you to wait thank you when last we
left a small chip high he was working on
he just finished dark night shooting yes
left London one home huzzah go home what
happens between shooting it in the movie
coming out you go to work and I went
back to work I mean you get a paycheck
for your time for the weeks that you
were working but then I would back
acting and what I was trying to do was
save up enough money to get myself to
Hollywood and I wanted it I wanted a
credit and all of a sudden I had like
four total so I went back to Chicago and
I got to I got to do some really amazing
place I did I did a production of as you
like it and then I did a production of a
Sam Shepard play that I had always
wanted to do and then I knew that I was
going to be going soon after that so I I
ended up you you also here's another
thing you guys like I told you before I
wouldn secure I was about my performance
in that film and it's a massive script
of which I only got to see two pages of
they didn't show me a whole script but I
knew they were shooting for eight and a
half months in three continents and I
thought there's a very great reality and
when it's happened to many many friends
of mine where you shoot something and
then so you can't and everyone says that
to you you know yeah it can be on the
cutting room floor or it could be shitty
so I remember I'll never forget getting
to go they had like a like they had a
big cast and crew opening in Chicago and
I got to go to a good cast and crew
screening of the film and sitting there
and watching it unfolding and
it it was a of the umpteenth surreal
stories of my own experience that I
could tell you guys that was another one
just seeing myself up there in that
world
I was like this isn't real and it didn't
even look real it looked like something
about it jars you were the first time
you see yourself up there does it it
doesn't look like it fits in the rest of
the film fixed thing maybe my mom had
made I don't know
so then I so then I was still saving up
money and and Christmas
he would put me in that commercial
before filmmaker Chris mcgahren I made
the wonderful American movie yep and he
did the yes-man in the pool and collapse
he's brilliant he was gonna do another
string of commercials and he called me
and he said I got the script and it's I
don't think it's very good but I think
you could do something fun with it so I
end up getting the job which we shot in
New York so I ended up actually living
for a year in New York mm-hmm and I was
able to save up even more money for my
goal to like get to Hollywood and I was
one save money living in doing
commercial doing burger commercial I did
literally we shot pray 50 some
commercials together they didn't air all
of those but I was on like a contract
with so I got to work with this amazing
director and the other actors in it were
good friends of mine were amazing and I
again learned how doing like this stuff
like being aware of this thing is so
vastly different than being on being on
a stage and trying to project to the
300-seat it's just it's all the same
tools gilsu absolutely so instead of an
audience of 350 you've got an audience
of whining and you're out how you
connect how do we play that like this
and use a microphone and all that stuff
so I got to I feel like I learned how to
camera act again for another year with
Chris and during that time I met the
woman who become my wife that happens I
was bringing that into the story I was
doing a hi honey I was doing I was doing
a short film I was I wanted to get in
front of the camera I sir that's the
lady was independent that to my
beautiful wife Evelyn yes yeah okay when
we go on those things those red carpet
things for movies it's hilarious because
we do pictures I always bring up there
and you make me look for me and in the
photographer is always like okay sir sir
sir sorry could we get a single on her
can you get off they always ask me to
get off
she looks like an actress you're like
I'm not the plus I was doing this these
really cool filmmakers who became good
friends of mine we're making a horror
short film about zombies at Fashion Week
and so I was shooting with them and Eve
had trained photography and so she was a
she was friends with the woman directing
this short and so she came for a day to
do like EPK and behind the scenes just
as like a favor and I see this girl
walking we're shooting a scene in a
salon in Brooklyn and I see this girl
walking around and I was like what is
that and then I walked up to her because
I'm the star of this short film about
zombies it fashionable you know what do
you what are you doing what are you
doing here and she's like oh I have to
interview you and our first conversation
is on camera and it's amazing because oh
I am so the plumes are so out like I'm
so like peacock is trying so hard to be
like yeah I'm playing this character his
name's dad and he's you know she was
like in the zombie thing at Fashion Week
like yeah yeah my second thing after the
know I'd done another short be back in
Chicago before that so then I head to LA
in in December so in January of 2010 I
moved to Los Angeles with her she and I
kept dating long-distance and I got to
LA and I got some more work back there
mm-hmm and by the time we finished that
but the following fall she moved out to
LA we've been together ever since and
now we're married and have a little boy
you got the kid or locate all right
Liz's before we jump into the [ __ ]
ant-man thing and the sushi girl thing
which puts you into Mark Hamill world as
well tell him the arlo story my my son
Arlo it's it's it's really fun because I
was saying to Kevin when we met I said
oh man what a coolest name for your
daughter it's like I know everything
about him you know it's weird when you
meet somebody and you know so much about
them you don't want to creep them out
and be like so I know the name of your
child
I mean to a difference a cure chair the
restraining order you really love he
knows too much about me I know I put so
much information out so people you know
we're saying to him oh yeah Harley Quinn
that's like nowadays people I call
original of it was so original when you
did and for me my son's name is Arlo and
people will come up to me often and say
Oh Arlo Guthrie your name you named your
son after Arlo Guthrie and I'm like no
as a matter of fact sir I my
great-grandparents Bertha be an Ernest C
Cobb were children's book authors back
in New England and they were they were
very indie they worked out of their
kitchen and they published their own
books for kids and they wrote these
awesome stories and they my my grandma
my mom would take him to two schools and
and this book that they wrote was called
Arlo about a little boy who's uh who
lives with this mean woman and he runs
away to find his parents and he takes up
with these minstrels and goes on this
adventure and and joins us revolution in
any way Woody Guthrie the famous
American folk musician was friends with
my great-grandparents in some weird way
and loved that book so he named his son
after the book that my
great-grandparents wrote so technically
you got you got three is named after the
book that I have more claim to so and I
and Disney actually apparently had the
the option on Arlo for a very long time
it lapsed in like the 70s and it's mine
now and one of my goals in life is I'm
very fascinated with I want to make
films for kids as well and I love
writing for kids and I have a TV show I
want to make for kids so I want to long
I want it I think it's there's a film in
there that I want to adapt [ __ ] one
generation removed from the creators of
the material in the family and you're
like oh I'm gonna make a movie in this I
kind of get this now I got a [ __ ]
charmed life man you trippin the amazing
thing I've been a bit dark nice and all
that's good in your world I've been
blessed man I it hasn't always been
great you know before I was when I was
when I was shoveling popcorn at the
movie theater and
and working the telemarketing job before
that I definitely hit I think everybody
people have their highs and their lows
in their life and I hit one particularly
low that was so low it's a whole other
podcast and we could talk about that but
um but yeah I'm really great but there
was a point in which I was sleeping in a
car which was actually I used to park at
different places in Chicago and one of
which was very near to where we shot
that scene in The Dark Knight and I'll
never forget standing there and thinking
like dude I used to like sleep down
there you know it's icky it's true I
mean I'm very blind very grateful man it
makes it makes every day now like
surreal you know it's weird that's you
[ __ ] like that you always hear like sad
actor story sad after stories you see
that ones y'all know and movies and [ __ ]
in the news those the big success
stories and stuff but whenever you talk
to a girl again I tried to make a little
bit that is a [ __ ] great story
thanks man I sort of feel like people
who are creative for some reason their
lives end up going as if it's a story
and you've got to have that point that
like middle of the second act where
everything is going wrong before you can
then rise and have your third act not
your second act but the big [ __ ] next
job that you had was the ant-man G yes
yes yes yes how did that so I've been
now working in in LA and I done some TV
shows I had done sushi girl which you
mentioned earlier we jump out real quick
before is an indie film directed by Kern
Saxton and it had Mark Hamill in it yeah
well coolest [ __ ] trailer you'll see
online yes an amazing [ __ ] truck
dudes dudes dudes if the cast is on is
really quite so you hamiltoe needs in it
Danny Trejo
Andy McKenzie Jeff Fahey Sonny Chiba has
a cameo in it oh that Courtney palm
James Duval
you know Noah Hathaway Atreyu from the
neverending story he's like the hero of
it we the table read when I first got
the way I got the part was I'd come to
LA and even though I had the Dark Knight
credit I couldn't get an agent I told
you this DoD I couldn't get anybody that
wanted to like stying me and I was going
to offices around it Beverly Hills and
handing off resumes and I did
I did you know saying I was Vince and
berry child in the award-winning and
they're delivering lunch or what no I
mean anyway so I Facebook messaged one
of the producers of sushi girl because I
had seen a breakdown of it on actors
axis and I didn't I didn't know how to
like reach people to get an audition for
something so I found a guy on Facebook
and I said I'm a direct message and said
I saw that you're making this movies
there any way I could audition for it
and he had just seen the Dark Knight
thankfully and they brought me and and
they got put me in the movie a great
role and I went I remember the table
read these are all new people to me mind
you I've just come to Hollywood and here
I'm sitting around a table with these
icons and these guys who represent the
kind of films that I've been watching my
whole life and I love and I got real
nervous as I do and I had to go number
two no oh yeah we's one out of the sushi
girl
nice nice home in I don't know what
neighborhood it's called but but not you
know not far from here in a nice
neighborhood and and and I'm and I and
then like where's the bathroom I don't
want to go to the one that's right off
the table upstairs I go it's quiet
enough great there's no toilet paper the
dream turned into it and I don't have
what am I gonna do there's one nice
cloth towel and like what am I gonna do
with I've got this director had texted
me earlier directions for to come for
the reading so I've got his phone number
and that's the only person that I could
possibly so I had to text the director
vague is there any way so and Kern who's
now a dear friend of mine like what
after this yeah but he made an awesome
movie and that was that was huge and
Mark and I I know you guys are friends
and you work together and he just and
he's been on the show and he he just we
just vibed immediately on well I'm a
huge fan of his joke
huge fan and they animated series as big
of a deal for me is it is weird you had
worked with the Joker and then you're
next and that was what he sees you as my
kids were saying that you know you were
dead and I went and watched it no yeah
and you were great
and I've said this before but they
always say don't meet your heroes and
that's [ __ ] because we compete the
ones that are like he's just an amazing
guy we bonded over William Castle going
to I use telling my I just went to send
a family and they were screening the
Tingler and they had the buzz eats and
he was like what I want to go do that
with you and we're friends now you know
I think he's he's great awesome dude he
left a message on your phone for you my
voicemail will will have to read okay I
don't have a signal in here but he he he
go it was we were wrapping sushi girl
and I had to go back to New York for
something else and he said oh you're
gonna miss the wrap party and I said
yeah and he's like I had a gift oh and
he recorded my incoming message which
has now been what's that for year five
years and it's young David can't come to
the phone right now he's all tied up he
does this great Joker and it's pretty
good yoga right there thank you I think
so yeah he so he left that which has
been to me huge and awesome it also
filters those people who call me often
from when they actually leave a message
I know it's important because it's a
very long it's like a minute more my mom
doesn't even call me anymore
she calls my wife's phone because when
you take that man scary Halloween is
over so they did that
and then a bunch of other really cool
stuff I got to work with denis
villeneuve on prisoners which was a
wonderful experience we made and then i
after prisoners i went and i had written
a script called animals which talks
about that dark time i was telling you
guys when it was really low and and and
we shot it for no money in chicago my
dear friends Colin Shipley and my wife
wouldn't help even though she's not in
the industry and we've this incredible
time picture from where that's from the
movie that's that's me and Kim Shaw who
directed his name's Colin Shipley and
you wrote I wrote it and I produced it
along with Chris Smith who was
embarrassed read the script and loved it
and Mary Pat Ben tell who's an awesome
film producer and Colin the four of us
and then and then we and then the do how
goes and then the army started to come
and the friends in the
people that pitched in to work on $150 a
day or some shot on Chicago in four
six-day weeks did you go foam fest it or
what so then we as soon as we wrapped it
Colin went to use Chris's um post house
in in Milwaukee at library films with
our amazing editor Amanda Griffin and
and Chris and berry poultry man all
helped and they got a cut of it and at
that point I got out of the way because
I've written the thing I acted in the
thing I'm like the worst person to be
giving knows because I'm looking at
performance I'm looking at my script and
a movie just you guys know it just
totally grows and changes after it gets
shot so I wanted to get away and they
submitted and the first place we
submitted we got into their competition
at South by Southwest one this really
cool award 2014 March that is 2014 but
mind you I'm back to like that movie
cost us kind of like months of being out
of the game we have no income my wife
and I my wife had quit her a regular job
to come to it with us and and we had
said like oh whoa we're not we're not
parents yet like we can go do this
because it's not like we had a kid boom
like four days before principal
photography and my wife's like so within
us finding out that we were pregnant
with our hello whatever how eight months
later we're at South by my wife's out to
here
we won this awesome award I was in the
midst of our dish a long audition
process for at that time Edgar for
ant-man right then Edgar right yeah man
I had auditioned for Edgar and then he
had set up a test for me and a bunch of
other actors come in and test for this
role of Scott Lang's crew so you were on
so even in Edgar's version you were on
Scott Lang's crew yes and I had to fly
back from South by early leaving my
eight month pregnant wife with our
friend call and it was a movie and and I
go back and I and they they they
postpone that test of course I fly back
they postpone the test and then they end
up doing it like a week or so later
while I was in Vancouver doing a show
called the intruders with the BBC and
and I tested
for for Edgar with at that point Paul
and Michael were set as cast and there
was a bunch of other guys testing with
us for the the crew and it's an amazing
story you guys it was like a Sunday my
wife found out she might be coming early
the baby might become an early I was
freaking out the people I was working
with up in Vancouver wrapped me out to
put me on a plane to send me back to LA
and I'm a checking account probably I'd
like a three grand in it and I'm like I
think having a baby costs a lot more
than that and if you're gonna be in Los
Angeles through Grandal last year two
minutes yeah so I'm like whatever is
meant to happen is meant to have him
right now and and my my my agent manager
called and said they're executing your
option like you're gonna be in ant-man
now and and it just I jumped on this bed
in this hotel room by myself and I hit
my head really hard on the sieve and it
caused all this [ __ ] to come down you
know and I came back and my son was born
the next day holy crap now wait which a
man we cast in Edgar Wright ant-man
so it's casting Edgar's this is what's
crazy okay so let's stop for one second
there's a man who walks between two
worlds because you were in Dark Knight a
DC movie and ant-man a Marvel movie but
yeah you the man who walks between two
worlds even within the Marvel Universe
because you were in a version of ant-man
that will never exist at this point
right and then you were in the version
of ant-man which everybody knows and
loves as well correct so tell us about
the one we'll never see the one that
we've never seen all I got to see when
you're testing and auditioning they
don't give you us they've they're not my
level of actor I think if you're a star
they give you a whole script to see oh I
like this when you're mean you go I'll
be in it they give you like and they
give you a list of ingredients on the
ketchup and that's your loss and don't
look done those eight pages I don't know
what was all going to be shot but it was
quite different I mean it was the crew
was much bigger the Scott's crew was a
number of guys and a lot of the humor
derived from that so the ant-man as we
know what Scott's crew is you Michael
Pena and yes Lewis and that's it yeah
yeah yeah what how many in his in that
version I walk I feel like there was a
grand total of either eight or seven
total which including Scott's maybe
there was like six guys and there was a
lot of when I was testing I remember a
lot of the jokes that I was
trying to make work and also be active
in like an action sequence were like
keeping track of people's names and
stuff like that
so that was kind of my bit you know and
I had this character that um I told you
this story when I went to the test I had
like an idea of how my hair would look
and I'd worn this because I like to show
up in character you know and and this
was such a this was at this point a
character if you've seen Ant Man the
character I playing is quite different
than characters I've gotten to play in
other films before so this was a big
stretch for me so I really wanted to
like you know let them see me as that so
I showed up he's cooked and I was in the
the thing like just from time I walk in
until it's time to do the thing and
we're doing scene with like Edgar it had
seen other stuff I'd been in and he and
he knew who I was so we had spoken out
of my dialect but um but I'd met Paul
Rudd for the first time and Pena for the
first time at this test at Disney and we
they're so nice we're like there's like
a coffee room where you're like eating
and then you go into the stage where
you're shooting some scenes like fake
scenes to see how you chemistry is I
guess or how you look together and then
Paul after it's a long day and Pollak
you know comes over at one point he's
like hey man great job in there you know
like how long have you when did you come
over or you know that's the best
compliment ever the truth is Paul Rudd
grew up in Kansas City in a city called
Overland Park pray a mile from where I
grew up he went to a high school called
Shawnee Mission West I went to show
yourself I knew that we had both worked
at the same mall at different times but
it's similar so I'm like in character
I'm like well I was for assistant
manager at Long John Silver at the Oak
Park Mall and he was like why you were
though and I was like dude I'm from but
so I get cast in Edgar's version and
then soon after Edgar did you know say
hey I'm really sorry it's been so great
getting to know you but I think I'm I'm
gonna be leaving the project and were
you like oh [ __ ] I was devastated
because I had stopped I hadn't been
looking for where I had been like enjoy
this baby and my wife and we're in our
apartment in LA going like dude
a couple months we're gonna go join the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are you
kidding me and then all of a sudden that
went away in a sense because they
started I knew that they were rewriting
the script in my agent and found out
that some of the guys who had been hired
as crew were we're leaving or getting
let go and people were leaving and it
was it was really stressful and and then
I heard that Peyton Reed had been hired
on as the director which I was so
excited for the film because I thought
oh I love that guy
and I know I'd seen him in interviews
before and I knew he had this like
similar knowledge or similar passion as
I did to like some of the source
material he loves comics and almost made
some great great cool movies great
[ __ ] phone lines like he deep but
they put him in movie Jail after down
with love yeah it's a good man it was
unfair spark because that's an
incredible movie yeah that really is a
snapshot of a movie they never [ __ ]
make anymore and it's pitch perfect and
tone and everything and then after that
for a while they were like but he's
something he's done do [ __ ] bring it
on [ __ ] movie like so when they
announced Tim is the backup guys like
Wyatt Edgar's and I can do it this guy's
gonna do it I was like number one that's
total Marvel Moneyball they go from
somebody who knows how to make these
movies but maybe hasn't at least they
used to in Marvel goes you know universe
1 or 2 whatever they [ __ ] call that
it seems now they're like now would get
anybody we don't have free inaudible
soon we'll see a Spielberg Marvel movie
that's my pretension but in any event
man there was that time we're like they
were like let's get people like Favreau
they got Favreau after as the thorough
flops and [ __ ] so they're like he knows
how to make a movie he made a movie that
hit with elf he made a movie that didn't
hit in space which we can't pronounce
but he knows how to handle a budget
let's give him this movie so when they
got paint read I was so happy because
I'm like finally somebody can [ __ ]
let this do that movie jealous [ __ ]
talented but right away I was like he's
a great blend for this material because
everything I know about the dude he
likes comics know so does Edgar yeah but
you know in a world where it wasn't
gonna be Edgar he seemed like a [ __ ]
good choice I was like right on and I
loved the movie like I still do well I
know you were you know you're a person
whose opinion matters to me and when you
said that you liked it we were all very
very pleased it's fun movies I like it
it's [ __ ] Iron Man structure with a
lot more
fun sure which yeah is that even
possible for a mark yes I was I was just
I was terrified because they it months
go and I don't hear anything and I was
supposed to start once a certain point
into when the contract was supposed to
start they did start paying me so I did
start getting some income but that
didn't me a mare was like I could be let
go and then what am I know it was really
it was really stressful and um and the
my agent called said oh good news you're
gonna go down and test with pay he said
you're going to go down and test with
Payton and I thought okay I'm gonna test
again
say it right I went down to do camera
tests like it was official if I got the
part I just wanna look at your car I
walk I go to Atlanta we go to pine the
new Pinewood Studios and his first movie
this is gonna be shot there and I go up
into this boardroom where the Marvel
executives are there and like the the
VFX guys are there and Peyton's there
and Paul and and and and Evangeline and
Pena and they do this big demonstration
for us and they bring out the ant-man
and I'm sitting there thinking like god
I'm so lucky I don't see any other guys
auditioning here and then pains like
alright man let's get you in some I've
got some ideas you know for how I want
the looks to go it's great to meet you
finally I'm so glad that we're doing
this and I'm like do you mean I'm like
I'm in but it's true but no one said
that to me they just anyway so yeah then
I went and shot and it was oh man it was
so fun that's all your guy I mean look
the whole [ __ ] movies fun but all the
stuff with the crew just look like balls
to the wall good time is it black
weather Paul Rudd was with you guys
whether you guys are off by ourselves in
the van and stuff like supporting
characters don't not good don't come
along very often to movies and stuff
like that crew you could watch all
[ __ ] movie about that crew
independent of Ant Man in the Marvel
Universe and still being a joke offer
sandwiches I'm so lucky that like those
the ideas and thoughts that go behind
the structure of the film and these
characters you got Edgar Wright and Joe
Cornish his vision in there and then
you've got Adam McKay and Paul Rudd's
vision in there and then
you know Gabe Ferrari and Andrew barrer
who are who wrote it on that as well and
are writing the next one all these
people's ideas and vision and I get to
go into these circumstances that are
just ripe for that can be really fun you
know and I'm with these brilliant actors
they would we'd always shoot the text
you know and then then they just start
and let it go and see where it goes and
they come in the next day with rewrites
based on stuff that had been done the
day before him and they would always
that's not my element or say you know
and they would kept throwing me ball the
ball and letting me play so there's I
like what you would don't they kept some
just like no no like what you were doing
so they were like you know they don't
always be like my god what you're doing
is great sometimes like knowing that
just like my improv that I like to work
this is the work of gypsies and oh and
they they're doing a titanic rift and
then I and I said the old lady not that
she still throw I also made some Funyun
fart jokes that didn't make it but
that's all right
I got pushed and I pushed I wonder to
close this I got to bring our load to
set one night the crew and they the
producers and everybody was so cool and
they loved this material as much as I do
and nor more even I don't know who could
love it more than than me but I keep
meeting people who loved it so much and
they were just like so into it and I got
to bring Arlo to set the night they're
shooting a the taint coming out of pim
laboratories and like he's just like
he's so he's a legend in aren't he's so
[ __ ] just cool and and and week we
started talking about um yeah I was
talking about him about him and working
on with Karl Malden back in the day and
be in the streets of San Francisco and I
love Karl Malden and I loved wood
you know that guy represented so much
about the great supporting actor and
then he and he did so many great
performances and we start talking about
that the next thing that led to talking
about Cuckoo's Nest which Douglass
helped bring to this race yeah I mean
the stories this dude has any Sophie's
funny and cool and
now he's hank pym and he's gonna hate
him and nailed it yeah nailed it yeah
and didn't nail Janet which he did in
the comics that was well yeah we're
punching sharks this hank pym he ain't
very punchy at all Hank's going through
some particle messes with the NIE and
who knows where they're gonna take this
though I hope they continue to play in
that fun tone because what I love about
the film and I'm really proud of it is
it does it just embodies like I say the
colors that I think of when I think of
when I first dove into these characters
and their their their sense of humor and
the way that they fought and the way
that you're able to have a massive
battle while they're still quipping to
one another I think that shit's right
from the mind of Stan and when I met
Stan for the first time you know he said
I'm so you know I'm so excited about
this because I'm gonna do a bad Stan Lee
Howard Stanley KGB and we're playing
with Excelsior Stan Stan Sam got brought
to do we're doing this his cameo at the
restaurant across brothers that story
were she's crazy-stupid fine man and
he's supposed to be mild in those words
he comes in and he no one really kind of
tells him what to do and he get to his
mark and any student he goes she's crazy
and stupid and she's fine she's
crazy-stupid fine man that's what I said
she's crazy and she is stupid and she's
fine why didn't someone tell me what he
got really like annoyed I was like oh
man Stan and then after uh after he
chief rapped he was he went shook
everyone's hands and I'm so excited
about this and and and I got to go to
his trailer and me and Paul and Brad
winter bond one of the producers and and
he said I I'm so excited to see this in
a film because in the comics ant-man was
always limited because you had to cut
back and forth between the frames of him
small and him big and it never really
operated the way we wanted it to for our
readers
and he said seeing it now in a movie we
could jump and we can save so much and
that can
he's really excited about it and and and
I and I told him about you know the
first comic that I bought and I told him
about my my life and we had this amazing
conversation and then it led to a
certain point me saying something like
you know I'm really nervous someday I'm
gonna bring the long boxes down when
Arlo's 9 and show him you know all that
I've got and he's gonna go like dude
like show me how to throw a curve ball
or something that I'm in he might be a
job and and and Stan took I brought the
the first comic I ever bought off a
spinning rack at a 7-eleven and he wrote
to my friend Arlo Stanley ah dude that's
amazing it's an heirloom for heaven's
sakes
yeah signed by the man himself yes lad
that [ __ ] it's I've got uh yeah Marvel
gave me some cool ones that's when you
intend never touch a book again I guess
I've got some I got some other ones is
gonna be just like something that Arlo
gets you god I want to read it I want to
read his first comic so guys say prayer
out and comic lover fandom that my son
otherwise man you could sell that to
some other lucky boy darling maybe all
of another kid my daughter's gonna love
comics who knows named her Harlow they
just put an H on the beginning of that
you're all set there you go
let me tell you something you are [ __ ]
chock-a-block full of goddamn
interesting stories dude everywhere is
everything you wanna be your being it
you're a places [ __ ] make making
people [ __ ] walking through history
pedicures meeting Kevin Smith getting a
pedicure people your place and you sit
out there and be like pedicure you jerk
that's who you meet when you go [ __ ]
pathetic you see in and you get shiny
toes that as well but even if you don't
man it's all about the small chip man as
well it's running someone like the small
chin Dave the small chin ladies and
gentlemen you know him but now you know
him that's what I like about this show
man like they know your face and [ __ ]
and as an actor probably better that
they lo know little about you because
then they could all without project your
[ __ ] back onto you right like you
pop up in the dark night nobody knows
who the [ __ ] you are so they like this
guy's [ __ ] riveting and [ __ ]
unfortunately we ruined your
sorry but because you just told everyone
you're plugging secret origin it should
now they're gonna be like oh you're
sweet guys got a kid that one nice wife
you can't be a psychic I played I played
I played my share cycles now there's
good Jeff Daniels roles you know huge
into Cheney both Cheney's senior and
junior I think Jimmy turtle I want those
guys to get in on the universe somewhere
this is not a but I've been watching Bad
News Bears a lot lately
Buscemi would be great it'd be so great
it has to have a [ __ ] look about you
see trees lately it's just not like way
back and watch it again recently and
it's like come on man that guy's just so
[ __ ] he's always been yeah you're gonna
come back and be on the show
I hope so just because I know there's
your mother said that you worked on
which we can't talk about now because
it's early but he worked as somebody
else I'll tell you right afterwards
about what and it's [ __ ] dope so as
soon as you're allowed to talk about it
I would love to be a great news here and
we'll talk about here cuz it was [ __ ]
like when he told me I was like no I'm
telling you like he's got the life you
want my guys I said they're getting my
feet done I was like I want to write
comics man come on I I saw somebody
where I was like I like your life better
and his wife was frightened or snide
Julie she rushed the kid out of there
there is go wide yes yes Jim goddamn
single oh no no he leaves there is Dave
the small chin man now you know him what
we [ __ ] is never mind he can't call
him The Joker dude anymore from ant-man
he was the frontman guy man he's totally
awesome now though I caught us two small
chin yeah that's just Dave now Dave
dismal thanks you guys this has been
amazing thank you you'll come back yes
there it is folks come on can't ask for
more than that it's [ __ ] fantastic
Oh tell your friends free thetic yours
you thought you had a cool life the
small chin not your [ __ ] right into the
dirt crazy makes us all feel small and
terrible but everyone is special in
their own way yeah you're all good it's
in your own way mark barnard Tom we are
they Dave dis mulchand [ __ ] you'll
see him back here again man come back
next week same bat-time same bat-channel
smart guess calm youtube.com backslash
Kevin Smith I'm taking care of the
business all better yeah well whatever
somebody's gotta
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder